[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen serien ihnen allen einen
schönen guten abend und für den sport
heute bei - kristin otto sehr gerne
guten abend dann sind hier unsere themen
an diesem montag
deutliches lohnplus gefordert die ig
metall will sieben bis acht prozent mehr
geld für die beschäftigten der metall
und elektroindustrie
was nun müsse präsident nach dem verlust
der absoluten mehrheit muss frankreichs
staatschef makro jetzt im parlament nach
partnern suchen
zeitenwende in kolumbien mit gustavo
petro erobert erstmals in der jüngeren
geschichte des landes ein linker den
präsidentenpalast
[Musik]
seit vielen wochen schwört uns die
regierung auf rauere zeiten ein darauf
dass auch wir die härten des krieges
spüren und wirtschaftlich mit abfedern
werden rekord energiepreise und
inflationsrate sprechen ja aktuell für
sich kein wunder dass jetzt ein
ausgleich angestrebt wird heute forderte
die größte deutsche gewerkschaft die ig
metall zwischen sieben und acht prozent
mehr lohn für die beschäftigten der
branche dazu stefan schlosser mit rund
3,8 millionen beschäftigten ist die
metall und elektrobranche das rückgrat
der deutschen industrie nach mehreren
jahren der zurückhaltung und angesichts
inflationsraten jenseits von sieben
prozent fordert die ig metall jetzt eine
kräftige lohnerhöhung von sieben bis
acht prozent für zwölf monate weil ein
los als sich die auslastung die aufträge
und ertragslage der industrie deutlich
besser entwickelt haben als im juli 20
21 vorhersehbar und weil bei aller
volatilität des umfeldes ja von heutiger
sicht davon ausgehen müssen dass diese
entwicklung weiter positiv verläuft eine
sicht die stefan wolf gar nicht teilen
kann er ist präsident von gesamtmetall
und führt gleichzeitig den
autozulieferer elringklinger ein konzern
mit weltweit rund 9.500 mitarbeitern von
guter ertragslage könne in der branche
keine rede sein in unserer industrie im
moment belastet mit rohstoffpreisen mit
hohen rohstoffpreisen mit hohem die
preise mit problemen in der lieferkette
viele unternehmen haben wirklich
schwierigkeiten ihre existenz zu sichern
hohe inflationsraten dazu hohe
lohnforderungen eine lohn-preis-spirale
könnte drohen wenn sich verbraucher
preise und löhne gegenseitig weiter
hochschaukeln aus volkswirtschaftlicher
sicht brauchen wir eine kompensation für
den kaufkraftverlust und andererseits
eben wollen wir eine lohn-preis-spirale
vermeiden und da sind einmalzahlungen
ein gutes element bei solchen
verhandlungen weil die etwas druck
herausnehmen doch einmalige
sonderzahlungen sind der ig metall
offenbar nicht genug sie will dauerhaft
höhere löhne ab september wird
verhandelt es dürfte eine harte
auseinandersetzung werden
auf diese tarifforderung könnte also
noch intensiver streit folgen der deutet
sich aktuell auch in der ampel regierung
an es geht um energie wegen russlands
gedrosselter gaslieferungen kündigt
ausgerechnet grünen wirtschaftsminister
habe kann zur stromgewinnung verstärkt
auf kohle zu setzen
kritik kommt aus der opposition aber
auch der mitregierenden fdp gehen die
pläne nicht weit genug patricia
wiedemeier
die lage sei extrem angespannt die
speicher längst nicht voll und über nord
stream 1 werden noch weniger gas nach
deutschland kommen als angenommen so das
ergebnis einer sitzung aller
landesenergieminister mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister heute mittag
wir werden anfang juli sogar noch in
eine revision der nordstream 1 kommen
das heißt er wird für mindestens zehn
tage die gesamte verbindung abgeschaltet
das könnte dazu führen dass wir sogar
wieder aus den speichern herausziehen
und gas brauchen werden schlecht der
aussichten in berlin verschärft sich die
debatte um alternativen zum gas die fdp
fordert fracking und atomkraft nicht
weiter auszuschließen wichtig ist die
drei verbliebenen kernkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen das ist ein faktum das
ist ein fakt was der wirtschaftsminister
aus meiner sicht so nicht ignorieren
kann doch kernkraftwerke einfach
weiterlaufen zu lassen nicht so einfach
es fehlt das personal neue brennstäbe zu
beschaffen erfordert zeit
sicherheitsüberprüfungen wären nötig so
untersucht des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums die beiden
anderen ampel partner lehnen die weitere
nutzung der atommeiler vehement ab klar
war allerdings auch dass diese debatten
um die verlängerung der atomenergie oder
die rückkehr des trackings dass wir das
ablehnen und dass es keine unterstützung
in der sozialdemokratie findet
beispielsweise viele fehler auf
treibstoff für den die brennelemente
dazu die gibt es nicht die kriegt man
auch auf die geschwindigkeit überhaupt
gar nicht hin und wenn das nicht geht
sollte man nicht irgendwie jetzt
künstliche debatten darum führen
einigkeit besteht derzeit nur darin dass
kohlekraftwerke vorübergehend wieder
mehr zum einsatz kommen sollen
nah dran in berlin ist theo koll theo
was erleben wir da gerade den anfang
eines ernsthaften ampel streits
ampel streit ja auch über grundsätze
aber nicht so ernsthaft dass die
koalition davon gefährdet wäre dennoch
geht es da zunehmend zur sache denn alle
drei ampel parteien haben ja durch die
folgen des ukraine kriegs schwere
politische tabubrüche vornehmen müssen
die spd bei der rüstung die fdp bei der
verschuldung und die grünen in dem sie
kohle kraftwerke wieder hochfahren
wollen interessanterweise sind die
politischen preisschilder diese
jeweiligen tabubrüche aber
unterschiedlich hoch vor allem die fdp
hat bei den landtagswahlen und in
umfragen er dafür deutlich bezahlen
müssen und auch deshalb zeigen die
liberalen jetzt die klarste kannte sie
haben vor einer halben stunde im
bundesvorstand einen beschluss gefasst
zur haushaltsdisziplin zitat mit der
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse den
finanzpolitischen ausnahmezustand
beenden also der ton wird rauer und bei
weiter zunehmender krise ist da auch
keine entspannung in sicht danke ins zdf
hauptstadtstudio theo koll ja es ist ein
herber rückschlag für frankreichs
präsidenten makro zum regieren braucht
er künftig einen koalitionspartner bei
den parlamentswahlen bleibt sein bündnis
der mitte ensemble mit 245 sitzen zwar
stärkste kraft verliert aber die
absolute mehrheit auf platz zwei das
linksbündnis mit jean-luc mélenchon mit
131 sitzen die rechte um marine le pen
hat im künftigen parlament so viele
sitze wie nie zuvor und auf platz vier
die konservativen und ihre verbündeten
aus paris an arendt
wohin steuert frankreich groß ist die
ungewissheit am tag nach einer
abstimmung die den präsidenten in
bedrängnis bringt denn marco muss sich
nun für jedes vorhaben verbündete aus
anderen politischen lagern suchen er
selbst schweigt bislang doch seine
premier ministerin erklärte noch am
wahlabend
wir werden alles daran setzen eine
handlungsfähige mehrheit zu bilden es
gibt keine alternative dazu um die
stabilität unseres landes zu
gewährleisten und die nötigen reformen
anzustoßen
unklar ob und wie ihm das gelingen kann
eine möglichkeit die allianz mit den
rechts konservativen la repubblica doch
die bekräftigen ihre oppositionsrolle
wir bleiben bei dieser linie es steht
nicht zur debatte dass wir einen pakt
eingehen koalieren oder sonstige
absprachen treffen
besonders gestärkt gehen die
populistischen parteien links wie rechts
aus der wahl hervor doch hier ist
ohnehin klar sie lehnen macros reformen
etwa die der rente vehement ab
stattdessen geben sie sich selbstbewusst
die von marine le pen geführten
rechtsnationalen etwa überraschend auf
platz drei fordern mehrere
schlüsselpositionen
wir haben jetzt ganz neue mittel um
unsere politischen ziele zu verteidigen
die eindämmung der chaotischen
einwanderung etwa und auch die erhöhung
der kaufkraft das wahlergebnis macht es
uns möglich denn noch nie waren wir so
stark im parlament vertreten
droht nun in der nationalversammlung
eine blockade zumindest dürfte sich die
partnersuche des präsidenten als
kompliziert erweisen frankreich stehen
ihnen politisch instabile zeiten davor
ja kein bequemes regieren mehr für den
französischen präsidenten thomas walde
in paris mit welchen auswirkungen für
deutschland für europa
außenpolitik ist laut französischer
verfassung die domäne des präsidenten dh
das gestrige ergebnis hat zunächst
einmal keine direkten auswirkungen auf
frankreichs außenpolitik auf die
internationalen beziehungen
aber marco ist innenpolitisch
angeschlagen hat an glaubwürdigkeit
verloren er wird viel zeit und energie
aufwenden müssen um hier zu lande etwas
regierungsfähige es zustande zu bringen
das ist zeit und energie die ihm
außenpolitisch dann fehlt und das
standing von staats- und regierungschefs
auf internationaler bühne hängt ja auch
von ihrer durchsetzungsfähigkeit zu
hause ab es ist kaum vorstellbar dass
marco auf europäischer ebene reformen
anstößt und durchsetzen will wenn ihm
das zu hause nicht einmal gelingen will
so hat er also alle hände voll hier zu
tun und das heißt mittelbar wirkt sich
diese war dann schon ausmachen kann auf
der internationalen bühne nicht mehr so
befreit aufspielen wie bisher
anordnungen von thomas walther in paris
vielen dank
ukrainische präsident willens sie
fürchtet dass die russischen angriffe in
den kommenden tagen noch heftiger werden
könnten und begründete es damit dass die
eu womöglich schon diese woche die
ukraine zum beitrittskandidaten erklären
könnte die ukraine spricht schon jetzt
von entscheidenden kämpfen russland
bombardiere vor allem die frontlinien im
osten und nordosten und trotzdem gibt es
auch immer wieder den versuch in der
ukraine so etwas wie alltag zu leben
nina kuschelten
[Applaus]
kinderlächeln inmitten von bomben und
krieg mit einem bus fahren freiwillige
von kriegs ort zu kriegs ort und lassen
die kinder durch magie musik und
geschenke einen moment lang den
traurigen alltag vergessen
diese party hier ist super es ist so
toll weil wir nicht mehr viel machen
können seitdem es den krieg gibt
sie helfen uns wieder glücklich zu sein
die kriegsrealität die russische seite
zeigt diese bilder und spricht von
positiven entwicklungen ihrer offensive
hier sieht man die tatsächlich eroberten
gebiete durch russland und russische
separatisten innerhalb der letzten 30
tage der ukrainische präsident so lenski
befürchtet dass die angriffe zunehmen
werden
natürlich erwarten wir dass russland
seine feindliche aktivität in dieser
woche verstärkt und das nicht nur uns
gegenüber sondern auch anderen
europäischen ländern wir bereiten uns
vor wir sind bereit in
den von der ukraine zurück eroberten
gebieten tonnen von blindgängern
verteilt auf einem gebiet fast so groß
wie deutschland
85.000 blindgänger haben wir auf
spielplätzen straßen und in häusern
gefunden
tagtäglich suchen und entschärfen sie
weiter immer mit der hoffnung hier
irgendwann einmal wieder friedlich leben
zu können
sie wissen wegen des krieges in viele
sanktionen gegen russland in kraft die
jetzt auch von der staatsanwaltschaft
münchen durchgesetzt wurden zum ersten
mal sind in deutschland immobilien eines
russischen ehepaars beschlagnahmt worden
der eigentümer der drei wohnungen in
münchen ist abgeordneter der russischen
staatsduma und steht auf der liste der
sanktionierten personen
schon im vorfeld hat die
kunstausstellung documenta in kassel für
diskussionen gesorgt es gab
antisemitismus vorwürfe jetzt ist daraus
scharfe kritik geworden aktueller
auslöser ist ein banner eines
indonesischen
künstlerkollektivs das bediene sich
einer antisemitischen bildsprache so
kulturstaatsministerin roth die
kunstfreiheit finde hier ihre grenzen
die dokumente leitung habe
offensichtlich beim thema antisemitismus
versagt sagte der vorsitzende des
zentralrates der juden schuster
eine nachricht aus israel die nicht ganz
unerwartet kommt die regierung ist
gescheitert die koalition der gegensätze
damit am ende es gibt neuwahlen bis
dahin wird wie im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart der ministerpräsident
gewechselt
abschied von der zentrumspartei
übernimmt das amt vom national
religiösen naftali bennett
fragen wir nach bei michael bewerunge in
tel aviv wieder einmal neuwahlen was
bedeutet das jetzt für israel
naja das sterben dieser regierung war
ein sterben auf raten oder sterben mit
ansage diese regierung hatte schon lange
ihre mehrheit im parlament verloren und
so war das vorgehen des führungsduos
bennet rapid jetzt mehr ein
verzweiflungsakt denn ein
befreiungsschlag es war von vornherein
klar dass es nicht weitergehen könnte
denn diese regierung ist letztendlich an
den gegensätzen gescheitert die von
vornherein sichtbar waren zum beispiel
die erstmalige historische teilnahme
einer arabisch islamischen partei in der
regierung am ende hat eine große
mehrheit der jüdischen israelis diese
teilnahme abgelehnt aber auch eine große
mehrheit der arabischen
palästinensischen israelis und so ist
dieses scheitern der koalition
eigentlich nur ein spiegelbild der
zerrissenheit insm gespaltenen land und
dieser gespaltenen region dankeschön
nach tel aviv michael bewerunge war das
jetzt nach südamerika kolumbien hat
einen neuen präsidenten mit gustavo
petro wurde zum ersten mal ein
linksgerichteter politiker ins höchste
staatsamt gewählt pedro bekam in der
stichwahl 50,4 prozent sein gegner der
reiche bauunternehmer ernanntes
47,3 pedro übernimmt ein land mit tiefer
sozialer und politischer spaltung die
versöhnung der nation eines seiner
wichtigsten ziele mehr erfahren wir von
christoph röck grad
es könnte nichts geringeres als eine
politische zeitenwende seien mit gustavo
petro zieht erstmals ein linker ex
guerilla 1 in kolumbiens
präsidentenpalast und seine ersten worte
nach dem sieg sind nicht die des kampfes
sondern der versöhnung
[Applaus]
das bedeutet zuerst einmal frieden
zweitens soziale gerechtigkeit und
drittens gerechtigkeit für die umwelt
am ende fiel die wahl nicht ganz so
knapp aus wie erwartet petrus
gegenkandidat der politisch schwer zu
verorten der millionär rudolph vor
hernandez hat seine niederlage
akzeptiert ein wichtiges signal in einem
land das nach mehr als 30 jahren
bürgerkrieg noch immer unter gewalt und
einem brüchigen friedensprozess leidet
gustavo petro hatte den bewaffneten
kampf schon vor jahrzehnten abgeschworen
er saß im gefängnis wurde gefoltert und
ging später in die politik war
bürgermeister von bogotá und diplomat in
belgien an seinem ziel das nicht nur
politisch gespaltene sondern auch von
großer wirtschaftlicher ungleichheit
geprägte land zu einen wird er sich
messen lassen müssen große erwartungen
richten sich auch an franz marc s die
als erste schwarze frau in das amt der
vizepräsidentin gewählt wurde
dies wird die regierung derer die
schwielen an den händen haben die barfuß
laufen die ganz unten sind
kolumbien hat den wandel gewählt nun
muss die neue regierung in umsetzen
viele menschen in deutschland haben sich
nach der gluthitze vom wochenende
bestimmt über etwas regen gefreut
besonders groß das aufatmen aber in
brandenburg die waldbrände südwestlich
von berlin sind unter kontrolle die lage
rund um treuenbrietzen und beelitz habe
sich deutlich entspannt so die behörden
hunderte anwohner können zurück in ihre
häuser glutnester müssen allerdings
weiter beobachtet werden die feuer
wurden vor allem durch heftige winde
immer wieder angefacht
jetzt zu den schwimm weltmeisterschaften
in budapest und weiteren medaillengewinn
sehr erfreulich einiges möglich morgen
abend ist dann der deutsche star der
szene im becken gefordert florian
wellbrock im finale über 800 meter
freistil dass er als zweitschnellster
erreicht hat hinter dem ukraine
romantschuk der seit kriegsbeginn mit
ihm in magdeburg trainiert
erstes wm-finale erreicht doch
florian wellbrock nicht wirklich mit
seinem vorlauf 7 minuten 44,75 sekunden
zu langsam dabei blieb er nur fünf
hundertstelsekunden hinter mir alle
romantschuk aus der ukraine
das 800 meter finale dann morgen für das
sich auch der olympiasieger
us-amerikaner bobby fink qualifiziert
hat heute morgen über 800 meter
ausgeschieden ist lukas merkens trotz
deutschem rekord im april er schwimmt
ein riesenprogramm und wurde vor einer
stunde im finale über 200 meter freistil
siegte nach seinem wm silber cool
gestern über die 400 meter freistil
aber ihm die luft raus und gleich kurz
vor 20 uhr hat anna elend goldchancen
als schnellste im halbfinale über 100
meter brust ist die 20-jährige favoriten
das ist spannend sechs siege in neuen
rennen die voraussetzungen für den
zweiten wm titel in der formel 1 die
titelverteidigung werden für max
verstappen immer besser mehr von stark
und äußerst clever hielt er auch in
montreal die konkurrenz auf abstand
große erleichterung im team von red bull
nach sieg von max verstappen beim großen
preis von kanada vom start weg liegt der
wm-führende vorne und baut seinen
vorsprung kontinuierlich aus bis juni
ziehen oder nach fahrfehler in der 51
von 70 runden eine safety-car-phase
erzwingt das feld bei restart wieder
ganz eng zusammengerückt max verstarb
man also noch mal mächtig unter druck
doch damit geht der weltmeister souverän
um der 24 jährige niederländer sieg vor
ferrari pilot carlos sainz und lewis
hamilton im stark verbesserten mercedes
mit schumacher nach fehlern den
vergangenen rennen diesmal im pech auf
rang sieben liegend scheidet der haas
pilot mit technischen defekt aus immer
neue chance in zwei wochen in
silverstone
dann fielen dank griff ihn morgen ist
übrigens astronomische sommeranfang das
wetter dazu hat gleich katja schäfer
christian sievers meldet sich um kurz
nach 10 mit dem heute journal das
gesamte heute 19 themen sagt danke fürs
interesse bis morgen und noch einen
entspannten abend für sie
[Musik]
guten abend dieses tief hier half die
waldbrände in brandenburg zu löschen
jetzt kommt allerdings erst mal kein
neuer regen hinterher an der ostseeküste
könnte ist heute nacht noch etwas regen
geben aus den alpen heraus und einzelne
gewitter möglich sonst ist es häufig
klar und dann wird es zum teil auch
wieder recht kalt mit 11 bis 4 grad
milder bleibt die nacht zwischen dem
chiemgau und dem oberrhein bei 15 bis 13
grad und morgen erwarten uns an der see
meister werte von 19 bis 20 grad sonst
24 bis 25 grad und im südwesten gehen
die temperaturen schon auf 28 bis 32
grad drauf das wird morgen ein
freundlicher dienstag häufig mit
sonnenschein mit nur wenigen wolken am
nachmittag allerdings könnte es über den
bergen einzelne gewitter geben wie zum
beispiel im schwarzwald mit diesem
sommerwetter geht es in den nächsten
tagen ungefähr so weiter im süden ist es
wärmer mit temperaturen von 30 oder 32
grad im norden ist es eher trocken da
scheint häufig die sonne und kräftigere
unwetter erwarten wir allerdings
frühestens am freitag dann mit
höchsttemperaturen von 23 bis 33 grad
guten abend